[Music]
jack hey neil it's that time again uh
yes it is i'm always excited when it's
that time
so i got something for you it's it's
comes up all the time in science fiction
and i get asked about it and you know it
is it's wormholes oh god yes okay
because people we're done with black
holes time to move on
exactly right and then of course there's
all the people who think that perhaps
the other side of a black hole is the
wormhole and i've heard that kind of
stuff talking yeah yeah so let me start
off with just a quick story i told this
story before but now it has a place to
land perfectly all right so some years
back in the early days of twitter i was
at an airport and i think it was north
carolina's charlotte's
charlotte airport it's a huge airport
and i had to go from a big plane to a
little plane and i had my luggage i
thought i'd be good and not have to
check my luggage but then i realized now
i have to carry the unchecked luggage
between two very widely separated points
in the airport so i'm there and i swear
it was like miles all right so i get to
the gate and i thought i'd be clever and
so i tweeted
can't wait until we have wormholes
and that way all gates are adjacent
to one another
okay you just sort of step through a
door there's the other thing that's the
other gate everything's connected by so
i thought i was being clever and then
someone cleverer than me
replies in my twitter comment threat dr
tyson
the day we have wormholes
you won't need airports
that's true yeah whoa
i just got totally served on that one
it's a wormhole just so people can
understand it
it's a
if you look at space and time we've
learned ever since einstein in 1916 when
he advanced the general theory of
relativity which is the modern
understanding of gravity
we learned that gravity
is the curvature
of space time space time yeah and what
you do is when you are falling towards
something you are simply sliding along
the
fabric of your space time towards
whatever it was that you were saying is
attracting you
and so it's an interesting it's a
different
construct
from just action at a distance you're
there i'm here we have gravity we pull
each other and that's it it's a whole
other thing going on
and if you think of
space and time as fabric right then you
can distort the fabric
with the force of gravity captain i
believe there's been a distortion in the
space-time continuum exactly so if you
if you ask yourself can i distort it in
interesting ways
that might benefit what i want to do in
the universe so for example i can get
you around among the planets using the
rockets that we've got and i can get you
there before you die all right uh so
moving around the solar system takes
days to the moon months to mars years to
the
to the outer planets and decade you know
maybe one or two decades to pluto if
you're okay to put that keep that on
your list if you wanted to go to a
non-planet if you want to go to
non-planet
the chuck is rubbing it i didn't rub
that one in chuck did i i thought i was
being charitable and even included it in
my thing and yes gotta start the fight
if you want to go to the uh to the uh
the lost member of the kuiper belt that
shouldn't even be invited to the party
yeah you know what are you gonna do
right
some people still have not gotten over
that joke
be sensitive to them so what happens is
if you want to visit other stars
then
every way we know to get there exceeds
the human life expectancy so
you have to find a way to shorten that
journey
knowing that the speed of light is not
just a good idea it's the law
right all right there's a speed limit to
how fast you can move in that fabric of
space and time the nearest star is four
light years away
at the speed of light you watch someone
go at the speed of light it'll take them
four years
to do that you say okay well let's just
do that then but we're nowhere near the
speed of light all right this is you
know so so it's hopeless and that's the
nearest star
so you imagine
let's is there a way
maybe you can
poke a hole
through or open up a hole
in the fabric of space and time
in a way that it's curved such that you
can take a shortcut from one location to
another nice so imagine if you had a
sheet
that so compress everything to a sheet
because otherwise it's hard to think of
bending four dimensions like so our
universe is now a sheet so if i take
that sheet normally i'd have to travel
the full length of the sheet to get from
a to b and i want to do that before the
tv commercial okay and so what do you do
you warp the space
and then
open up a hole
from one side to the other where the two
places are close in this higher
dimension right and by doing so you
basically take this portal through come
out the other side unfold the paper the
page and you've traveled all that
distance in no time at all it basically
and the no time part is well how much
did you warp the space in order to do
that how and if it you warp it a lot it
can happen basically instantly like
walking through a doorway or if it's
warped a little less then it'll take you
a little longer but in all cases
your effective speed
is way greater than the speed of light
because you basically cheated and
went across the other side now here i'm
doing this with my hands and things and
you told me you solved that problem you
have warped space in your living room i
did and
so
a couple years ago you did that
explanation
not on camera but we were just at the
museum
and you took a piece of paper and you
drew two dots on the paper then you
joined the two dots and you put a pencil
through it and you were like that's
your wormhole travel
so i
with my new favorite thing in the world
it's called glowforge it's a 3d laser
printer
which allows you to
cut
all kinds of things which i actually
made the fabric of space that's the
black side right and then just for
demonstration i made you know
this other side which is red wait wait
wait you gave space a black side i gave
it that's right
finally
you making sure finally space has a
black side okay
and then for contrast i painted this
other side red but here's the cool thing
i took your demonstration okay so here's
that sheet okay
and then you bend this
right and then just
and now what i have
is my wormhole man check that out and
just like you said
if i warp space closer then my time
travel is diminished but if i warp it
less i'm still traveling a shorter
distance but as you can see it's a
little longer i'm so into this neil i
took video of it and everything oh
really
i mean i made video of this
it is the coolest thing i have now i'm
kind of a crafty person like i like
painting and like sanding chairs and
paint you know like i look at etsy i'm
not gonna lie just to see what people
are doing but like i'm not so crafty
that i would ever make anything for
somebody
but i'm making everything for everybody
you will never get a gift from me that
didn't come from a glow forget
[Music]
i'm dead serious
that is how cool this thing is
okay every single every single
striation every single cut that you see
here was made by the 3d laser printer
what you're saying what you're implying
is since the damn thing can make
wormholes out of the space-time
continuum of the universe yes you can
make any damn thing
i am i'm telling you i am fascinated by
this thing i am in love with this thing
so anyway that's the wormhole that you
just talked about okay that might be the
only wormhole we get to have because why
what i didn't tell you
is that it's one thing to have a black
hole that all space and time collapses
on itself right to a singularity but
what you now want
is a hole through the fabric of space
that remains open
and the configuration of matter and
energy to create a hole
is unstable
against collapse
oh no so so in other words you can have
a stable black hole there that's sucking
in it you know
distorting the fabric of space and time
but a wormhole requires actively holding
it up
so that while you're in there it doesn't
collapse on you whereas you made one
that's stable
see we got to learn the secret
engineering of that so basically people
what you're looking at right here is the
only stable wormhole
in the universe
you're welcome
you're welcome that's all i'm saying
[Music]
so what did you do you clip on it's a
spiral shape so you clipped it on
together so it's it hooks in and then
you get it's like a little accordion so
yeah it's a spiral shape and then all i
did was so the design as you can see
here has a small
hole in the middle of the black hole
and then i just put a little peg in
there it actually cut a peg that i could
put in there this thing did yeah it
actually cut a peg that i could put in
here this thing's amazing so the thing
is a black hole
most understandings of a black hole have
you dying if you fall in if you can pry
open a worm because you end up at the
singularity right
smooshed and spaghettified and stretched
and and broken but a
a wormhole if it's opened and maintained
it could do one of several things it
could be a a whole
to another part of our own universe
which is what you've just done because
you you curved your universe and you're
just going from one location to another
or you can imagine
wormholing
out of our universe
into
another universe so in that case you'd
have to print two of those
and have
two of their their sort of coily um
whole structures intersect and that way
people in one universe would go through
that and show up in another universe now
the cool part is if you break the
wormhole and collapse it then you left
your universe never to return again
i'm on it
i'll be right back wait wait are the
belt collectors that close to your door
oh
how great believe it i i'm in so much
debt i'm sure there's bill collectors in
the next dimension as well they're like
we've been we've been waiting for you
chuck
[Laughter]
what's it called extradition i guess
from extradition yeah interdimensional
extradition there you go cool cool yeah
so so wormholes are fascinating and of
course they show up in so many different
movies all right uh in bill and ted's
excellent adventure their their time
traveling phone booth is basically a
wormhole right oddly in the movie back
to the future they're not they don't
appear to be traveling they are it is a
wormhole but you know it's a it's a it's
a portal
rather than an actual extended wormhole
they just exit one time and enter into
another right and one flaw but i'll give
it to them because they did so much else
right in
uh back to the future is when they leave
the parking lot
and end up respecting the future one
they uh leave the park at 88 miles an
hour right and they show up in the
cornfield in the farm fields that would
become that that um
that uh strip mall
what they didn't factor in is that
between those two times earth would have
moved in its orbit
you can't only travel back in time you
have to also travel back in space if you
want to land where you expect to land
from where you left
so if he would have time traveled back
and landed and in the vacuum of space
and they all would have died and the
movie would have lasted 15 minutes
well now yeah nobody's seeing that neil
nobody's going to see that movie
so the point is your wormhole if it's
going to go anywhere you want it it's
got to go somewhere otherwise it's not
only in time but in space all right you
want to make sure that it works out that
way um so also is that movie in uh time
bandits that was a
um
what's that from the 80s that one
was the monty python crew
so that one was wormholes in the movie
contact jody foster basically goes
through a wormhole
and so you know it's kind of fun
cinematically to display one of these to
portray them as you're going through and
it's basically like a tunnel
and and you know in a way maybe the old
tv show time tunnel
was an earlier concept of a wormhole
although at that time i don't think we
had the term yet for it
so by the way one of the
earliest statements about the existence
of wormholes was the idea that
if a black hole absorbs everything that
comes near it
let's let's take a look at the math
surrounding the black hole and you find
out that there are two solutions to that
equation that gives you the black hole
one of them absorbs everything and one
emits everything right
okay so something that emits everything
at all times is a time reversed black
hole so you can ask hmm
where does everything go that enters a
black hole
maybe it's what's coming out
on the other side which we'll call a
white hole
how would you connect them
you connect them with a wormhole
all right so wormholes have very high
utility
if you're trying to think about um
fun and interesting and useful
uh bendings of the fabrics of space and
time and you got a damn printer that'll
make that every day and i was going to
say you could do all that or you could
just get a glowforge
you could you could do all that or you
could just go get a glow forge and you
could make your own black hole and your
own wormhole can you make one big enough
so that you could go through it and then
you're gone so so if the next explainer
video i said chuck
where's
gone fishing you know
there you go yeah so uh i have to tell
you i'm looking forward to uh figuring
out first of all i think of everything
now when i see stuff i'm like can i
glowforge that that honestly is my new
that's how they smell okay that's how
that's how cool this thing is so i'm
hoping that uh we will have the
opportunity to talk about more stuff
maybe that we can sponsor this let's get
them to sponsor this oh that well yeah
that without a doubt i mean let's do
that they better don't tell anybody
yeah i i have to say though um
glowfords you saved my christmas
that's all i can say
if if you know me you know what you're
getting
all right
our first explainer video where chuck
now has toys yes okay
all right chuck we got to end it there
all right
all right uh that's been fun talking
about uh wormholes
and and like i said try to stay in this
universe we we have more work for you
okay okay yes um i might become
bi-universal that's all i can say
buy universal yeah man
all right this has been star talk an
explainer video i'm neil degrasse tyson
your personal astrophysicist
keep looking
[Music]
you